NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We rent digital books
for $5 a day.
Are you nuts?
I have spent
zero Marketing dollars.
You're just
a Marketing machine.
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
You're saying it's worth
a million dollars?
Absolutely.
How many
have you sold?
450.
You are an inventor,
not an entrepreneur.
O'LEARY:
You will have no hair.
You will both look like me
when this is over.
NARRATOR: If the sharks hear
a great idea...
You have
a great business.
...They're ready to invest
using their own money.
[ laughter ]
and they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I want 70%.
70%?! What is wrong
with you?
I have a guy.
I'm not gonna give you all the
verbal diarrhea you just heard.
Cut that crap out.
Now it got
a little serious here.
Kevin, come on,
work with me here, Kevin.
Listen, I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I know everything.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
My name is Pat Crowley.
I live in beautiful
Salt Lake city, Utah.
And I'm the founder
of Chapul.
[ dog barks ]
As an environmentalist,
I'm very concerned about
the future of our planet.
And so that's what inspired me
to create
an eco-friendly energy bar.
Right now we work
in a very small kitchen,
and we make all the bars
by hand.
Our product is the first
of its kind in the world.
It contains an extremely
healthy, sustainable form
of protein
that we like to refer to
as our secret ingredient.
Hello. Chapul.
This is Pat speaking.
We're growing every month, and
we can't keep up with demand.
We need an investment
from the sharks
to increase our production
and get the word out
about our amazing product.
Yeah, stoked on the new design.
It looks good.
Starting Chapul
has been a challenge.
People have called us crazy
and said that the idea
would never work.
Wanting a deal today
goes well beyond my desire
for personal success.
I want to propel this protein
as the food of the future.
My name is Pat Crowley,
from Salt Lake city, Utah.
My company is Chapul,
and I'm asking $50,000
in exchange for 5% equity
in our company.
At Chapul, we're changing
the way people think about food,
and we do it
with an energy bar.
But what separates us from
the thousands of competitors
isn't the delicious
medjool dates
or the organic dark chocolate.
No, it's our sustainable,
eco-friendly form of protein
that goes
into every single bar.
I'll show you,
but first, a joke.
[ laughter ]
Why are frogs so happy?
Uh-oh. Why?
Why?
Because they eat
what bugs them.
[ laughter ]
And now, so can you
with Chapul cricket bars.
Oh, you got
to be kidding.
Crickets are an extremely
sustainable form of protein.
They go into each one
of our bars.
Ohh.
I-insects are eaten in over half
the countries around the globe,
and we think that it's
about time that Americans
catch up
with the rest of the world.
There is no way
I'm eating that.
[ laughter ]
All right, we have
a thailand-themed
coconut ginger lime.
T-this one?
Yep.
Aztec bar is dark chocolate
coffee cayenne.
And then we have an all-american
peanut butter and chocolate.
Why not? Right?
HERJAVEC: They're crickets,
not cockroaches.
Correct.
We actually make a flour
out of the crickets...
Thank you.
...So you won't see
any legs or antennae.
[ laughter ]
You first.
Must we eat it?
Sure.
You're obviously jumping
at the opportunity here
to get on board
with a growing global business.
So, who wants to join Chapul
and help us to feed
the revolution?
You realize that there's
a huge barrier...
Absolutely.
...Around this product.
Some very large percentage
of consumers
are going to be revolted
because in our north
American society, they
don't eat insects.
I'm not saying it's good or bad.
They just don't.
I agree.
So, what I'm trying
to determine,
because I'm trying
to be pragmatic --
I'm happy to invest in it
if I can make money.
Sure. So, we modeled our energy
bar after the sushi industry.
30 years ago,
eating raw fish was completely
repulsive to Americans,
and -- until a man by the name
of ichiro mashita
craftily developed
the California roll,
and it was
a gentle introduction.
And so, that's what we're doing
with our ener--
but that took 20 years.
CUBAN: Tell --
talk about sales.
Okay, so, we -- to date,
we have, uh, $50,000 in sales,
and this year,
we're averaging
33% increase
month over month revenue.
So, over what period of time
would you say $50,000?
Oh. That's in
just under a year.
Where are you in retail?
Natural-foods stores,
bike shops,
rock-climbing gyms,
crossfit gyms.
You're saying it's worth
a million dollars?
Absolutely.
Well, why can't I
just get my own crickets
and make my own bars?
[ laughter ]
W-we've spent a lot of time
developing the supply chain
and working with the FDA,
and we're the only ones
right now
with an insect-based nutritional
product on the Market.
Only one that can sell
cricket bars?
We're the only ones doing it.
And one bar -- what do you
sell it for?
$2.99.
And to make it?
It costs about a dollar.
Where do you get
your crickets?
Do you grow them yourself?
You catch them?
We work with -- we work with
a cricket ranch, actually.
[ laughter ]
And do you -- do you --
They have --
they have little lassos.
Little cricket brands.
Where is there
a cricket ranch?
We've been raising crickets
in the -- in the United States
for over 100 years,
and it was based on --
why?
Fishing bait,
then it was reptile feed,
and now that was one of
the reasons we chose crickets,
is because the infrastructure
is already in place
to grow them at a large scale.
Are cricket farms
enclosed?
They are, and th-that's one
of the environmental benefits,
is that you can grow them
in a warehouse,
and it's significantly fewer
acres to grow more protein.
I'm interested
in how they meet their end.
You put them in a blender
and they stay to the sides,
and they fall down
and get s-- fried?
what happens?
We freeze them.
That's about the best way to go.
So it's -- it -- actually,
their natural metabolism
just slows down.
[ laughs ]
Pat, what does this
replace?
Like, do I eat this
and it's half the size
of a normal bar?
A bar with other all-natural
and organic ingredients...
Right.
...Would have half the protein
that that does.
So, you grind your crickets up
into flour?
Our name, Chapul, is actually
an Aztec word for "cricket,"
'cause they would do
the same thing.
They would gather crickets,
blend them up into a flour,
and make a protein-dense bread.
Look, I got to tell you.
I'm -- I'm a pretty brave guy,
but snakes, bugs...
Not brave enough, huh?
...Freak me right out.
So there's no way
I'm eating this stuff.
Thank you. I'm out.
O'LEARY: Let's -- let's talk
about the crickets,
because you didn't tell
the whole cricket story.
The truth about crickets
are that they are considered
a very important insect in many
countries around the world.
CROWLEY: Absolutely.
They're considered lucky.
Absolutely.
For example, in China,
people think
it's incredibly unlucky to kill
one, even accidentally.
How do you know that?
[ laughter ]
Listen, I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I know everything.
It's considered
really bad karma
to kill them,
let alone freeze them.
You got a whole bunch
of crickets right here.
They're not chirping
'cause they sense danger.
I agree. I agree.
That's what they sense.
You -- they know they're gonna
die a horrible death with you.
I just think, in this case,
those crickets are telling me
to stay out of this deal.
I'm out.
CORCORAN:
I have to hand it to you.
I ate that,
and it tastes great.
I can't tell the difference,
and I'm relieved to find out
that that crunch
that's on my tongue
are not the legs
of the crickets
and all that kind
of goofy stuff.
CUBAN: [ laughs ]
I think it's gonna be
a heck of a long journey
to convince people
that they're gonna love
to bite into something
with crickets in it.
I just think it is.
And whenever there's
a long journey in a business,
it means it costs you
more money to get there.
I'm out.
We-we've been very concerted
in our growth right now.
We've been intentionally trying
to fly under the radar
to some degree,
u-unsuccessfully.
We've been in national,
international publications
because of this.
I can't wrap my head
o-- around this.
I spend most of my life
trying to get away from
bugs, not eat them.
[ laughs ]
So, I'm sorry. I'm out.
All right, let's do this, Mark.
Let's do this.
CUBAN: Me and you.
Okay, Jiminy.
[ laughter ]
With the work you've done
to create cricket flour,
you're basically saying there's
no competition at all?
There's a couple
of up-and-coming companies.
What are they doing
compared to you guys?
What are they using
for flour?
They don't have
a product yet.
They've asked us
to sell it to them.
And we're --
we're debating right now whether
we should actually do that.
And why --
what's the debate?
Our business model is not
to invest in infrastructure,
and so I'd prefer
to purchase the flour
at some point if I could
and just be the brand
behind...
Wait.
...The insect movement.
I thou-- my understanding was
you own the flour, right?
We do. We do.
You created it,
that you're --
no one else has
this flour but you.
Correct.
From an FDA
perspective...
Right.
...You're the only one
that's approved, right?
Correct.
So why not have -- go to
these other guys and say,
"Okay, we'll sell you
our flour at, you know,
"three times
what it costs us to make,
but you have to brand it
'made with Chapul flour'"?
That's what -- that's why I say
we're -- we're on the fence,
and that's
what we're going to do
if we decide
to sell the flour.
Why wouldn't you do that?
It's a great idea.
I got to tell you,
the longer you're talking,
the more I realize you --
you have a great business.
But the business
is the flour.
The business
is not the energy bar.
Come on back in.
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out,
but Robert may have had
a change of heart.
HERJAVEC: I got to tell you,
the longer you're talking,
the more I realize you --
you have a great business.
But the business
is the flour.
The business
is not the energy bar.
is the flour.
Come on back in.
We do have a lot
of people saying,
"When are you gonna sell
the flour,
when are you gonna sell
the flour?"
Right.
one reason I've held off
on doing that
is that I'm --
my passion is
the sustainability
of our food systems.
I love the fact
that you're exclusive.
You have no competition.
I mean --
yeah, it's great.
I'd like to be able
to help you,
but it's not worth my time
for 5%.
Sell me.
I-i'd be happy
to take more money.
I could do that for you,
if you want.
Oh, really?
[ laughter ]
that is so generous of you,
but it doesn't work for me,
right?
Okay.
Sell me.
Yeah, okay.
So, we're projecting $150,000
in sales.
I'm -- I'm --
we're past that, right?
Okay.
We're negotiating.
A-- like I'm saying,
we are at the brink.
We're a-- we're on the whole --
forget that.
we're negotiating.
he's past all that.
We're negotiat--
now it's numbers.
He wants to know --
talk money. talk money.
we're negotiating numbers.
CROWLEY:
All right, all right.
You want me to come back
with another offer?
Yeah.
You got to make it
cricket sweet for him.
Make me an offer.
All right, so, i-i know
what it takes to lead a team,
and I need to maintain
complete ownership,
so I need to maintain 51%
to lead the team that I have.
Okay, so you have
other investors?
Not investors, but, uh,
employees -- founders.
Foun-- that have equity?
That have equity.
Okay, so --
I have 80%.
You have 80%?
Right.
So...Let's do 10%.
Make me an offer.
This is going to be...
...A $100 million business
in the next 5 years.
With any luck at all,
you might show a profit
before you're dead.
15% I could do, Mark.
Are you nuts?
Pat, I'll give you
the $50,000 for 20%.
Ooh, somebody
jumped back in.
I'll do it
for the 15%.
15%?
Yep.
Let's do this.
Let's do this, Mark.
Let's go make
some chirping money.
Appreciate it, buddy.
Thank you very much.
He snatched that one
from you.
CORCORAN: [ laughs ]
CUBAN:
Let's eat some crickets.
yeah, let's eat
some crickets.
Good job, man.
Thank you very much.
Robert, here's
your consolation prize.
Oh, don't come near me.
[ laughter ]
oh, my God.
CROWLEY: I definitely gave away
more equity than I wanted,
but now that Mark
is one of our partners,
we can't be more excited to just
take this to the next level
and really feed the revolution.
You cost me 5%.
I'm not gonna let you
live that down. I'm
gonna get that back.
You were trying to get 20%
out of him?
Yeah.
Yeah, but Robert ruined that
for you.
[ groans ]
They are so ugly.
NARRATOR:
This season, we watched
Eric Child and Spencer Quinn
strike a deal
with Lori Greiner
for their multi-purpose
repair product, Fiberfix.
Lori...
You have a deal.
Good.
NARRATOR: Let's see
what they're up to now.
[ train whistle blows ]
Prior to "Shark Tank,"
we had only done
about $300,000 in sales.
But since "Shark Tank,"
in only three months,
we've done almost $6 million
in sales nationwide.
Look at that.
10,000 units.
One of the reasons we decided
to partner with Lori
is because we knew
she brought
a ton of expertise
in home shopping.
Here we go. Look at this.
That was fiberfix.
Unbelievably strong,
this stuff.
QUINN: The day
after "Shark Tank" aired,
we were able to get
into one
of the most coveted positions
on QVC.
We have now taken orders
for over 10,000 kits.
[ laughs ]
and we were able to sell
through 45,000 rolls of fiberfix
in only 10 minutes.
We have sold out of everything
that we brought in.
Hey, we got to get 2,000 boxes
out today.
Can we do it?
[ cheering ]
All right! Let's do it!
CHILD: We've had so much demand
since "Shark Tank"
that we've had to move into
this 8,200-square-foot facility,
and we now have
a dedicated factory
that's producing over 10,000
rolls of fiberfix every day.
Fiberfix can now
be found in Home Depot,
ace hardware,
true value,
and many other retailers
nationwide.
We like to think
that we're continuing
the tradition
of American innovation.
It's awesome to be able
to create jobs
and provide a living wage
for lots of employees.
Our most exciting news yet
is the deal that Lori helped us
put together with Lowe's.
We're rolling out to all
1,800 stores nationwide.
So, do you all love it?
Hey, look who's here.
Hey!
GREINER: I've never seen
a product like this one.
There's nothing else
out there like it.
This is mandatory for everybody
to have in their home.
I think fiberfix
is going to be enormous.
CHILD: Doing our deal with Lori
has collapsed
three to five years of growth
to just a few months.
It's been an amazing ride
so far,
and we're excited to see
what the future holds.
ALL: Fiberfix it! Whoo!
NARRATOR:
Next up is a product
that solves
an alarming security issue
every homeowner
should know about.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Bryan White.
And my company is
the Garage Door Lock.
And I'm here seeking $275,000
for 30% equity in my company.
There!
It just happened.
There's a home invasion every
15 seconds in this country.
So, think about it.
What's the biggest door
in your house,
and which is the only door
you never lock?
The garage door.
Most people never give it
a second thought
because most people
don't realize
how easy it is
for thieves to break in.
There!
It just happened again.
The door is open in seconds,
and all you're left with are
some old, rusty paint cans
and oil stains on the floor.
The Garage Door Lock
is the answer.
It's a steel deadbolt
that automatically
locks your garage door
to protect your belongings
and to give you peace of mind.
The Garage Door Lock
is universal.
It works with all openers
on any door.
We lock every other door
in our home.
Why leave
the largest one unlocked?
So, come on, sharks,
let's close the deal
and lock this thing up.
Bryan, my garage door
is locked all the time.
No, your garage door is
not locked all the time.
That's a facade.
You're telling me that
my traditional garage door,
that I use my clicker on --
I have for years --
that's not safe?
Somebody can just walk
in there,
open it up
just like this thief did?
Correct.
Wow.
If you could imagine breaking
into a locked vehicle
with a slim Jim and -- or a coat
hanger, it's very similar.
Wow.
You know that guy that --
from the hood that I'm
always talking about?
[ laughter ]
CUBAN: Yep. That's --
there he is.
Hey, that's him
right there.
O'LEARY: Okay, so --
HERJAVEC: So, how does
your product work, Bryan?
How -- how do we --
how do we solve
this horrific problem
that is all over America?
Will it actually
stop the madness?
Stop the madness.
The way it works is when you --
when you push your remote
that comes with the lock kit,
the lock will unlock,
then you would --
you would close it,
and it would lock
a-automatically.
O'LEARY: So, hang on.
Is this an add-on that I put on
to my existing garage door?
Yes, you don't need
to replace --
but why -- but why doesn't
the manufacturer
that sold me the door
in the first place
just do the same thing?
Why do I -- why are they selling
me a crappy garage door?
WHITE: They're all sold,
they're all made the same way.
Do you install it yourself?
It's a do-it-yourself product.
It comes with
all the hardware needed and
the instructions to do it.
And how long
does it take to install?
WHITE:
For me, about 45 minutes,
but it would take somebody
that's never done one before
probably about a couple hours.
And what do you sell it for?
We're selling them now
for $249.95.
How many have you sold?
Total to date -- 450...
...For about $112,000.
And where are you
selling them at?
Just online.
We have ze-- I have spent
zero Marketing dollars.
I've just put up the webs--
how do people find --
how are people finding you?
Usually after they
get broken in.
Bryan, here's the biggest
problem with your product.
How are you gonna educate
the Market for this?
Well, that's --
that's part --
that's why he's here.
yeah. exactly.
That's what I was depending
on you guys for. I -- you know?
That's not
your strength, huh?
Hmm.
Oh, that's
a tough one there.
So, you know the problem for --
I've taken it this far.
Have you done a video
for YouTube or anything?
Yes, I have
a YouTube video.
And have you gotten
much response to it?
Yes. Actually,
the sales spiked in 2010
when that video went up.
And did you do
a follow-up?
No.
You're just
a Marketing machine.
[ laughter ]
O'LEARY:
So, Bryan, if I invest --
I love the honesty,
though.
JOHN: Bryan, can you --
I love the honesty.
I can't help it.
It's who I am.
Bryan, Bryan,
Bryan, since you said --
Bryan, would you like to go
to retail with this?
yes.
But do you know anything
about that? What's your history?
Well, I have invented a --
you ever been parasailing,
or you know
what parasailing is?
yes.
I invented the device
that launches parasails
from a boat
and pulls it back in.
But I see those
all around the world.
Right.
Well, that patent's long
expired. That was back in 1979.
Were you broken in?
Is this how you invented --
that's how I came up --
yeah.
I was living in a condominium
where there were, uh --
the garages were separate
from the residence.
People were going out and buying
the -- you know, the padlocks.
And they would have to go out,
unlock the door,
open the door, get in the car,
back it out.
How much money did you put into
the business to get it started?
We've got $250,000
into this,
not including
the patent money.
O'LEARY:
You're a -- you've built a
better mousetrap. Get that.
Now, I don't know
how to sell it
unless I want to come and work
with you in your garage
and do all
the Marketing myself.
If you could get me in front
of the -- the right people
and get in the big-box stores,
I will do the work.
I'm probably the most --
hardest-working guy you
ever met.
And I do have
a confidential agreement
to be introduced
to a large garage-door
manufacturing company.
What do you mean, to be
introduced to them?
I have
a guaranteed introduction.
[ chuckles ]
JOHN: Huh?
That's one
we've never heard of.
Yeah, I've never heard that.
What does that mean?
WHITE: That means the --
the person I'm working with
is very good friends
with the owner
of a major garage-door
manufacturer.
Oh.
You know, you got to be careful
with stuff like that.
Anybody who's charging you
for introduction
or stuff like that is
usually, uh...
a crook.
Yeah, so you've got to be
careful with that.
Can I tell you what you're
missing in this deal?
The most important ingredient.
You're missing an entrepreneur.
I am sure you are
probably the nicest person
we've ever met, period.
Thank you.
However --
but still,
she'll insult you.
However, I can't
even imagine you
walking into a big-box store,
I can't imagine you tracking
down billing, getting paid,
even if you had the sale.
You are an inventor,
not an entrepreneur.
I don't think you're gonna have
a easy time at all
getting people to invest
until you have
a great sales front
linked with your arm, standing
right there with you.
Um, that's what I was hoping
to get here.
Okay, well, until you get that,
I'm out.
Well, uh, you know,
it didn't take me long
for you to demonstrate how easy
and shock you into seeing...
CORCORAN: Terrific product,
no doubt.
...How valuable the product is,
so I don't know that it's
that hard to do.
The business is worthless
until the product is sold.
Bryan, I'm not gonna give you
all the verbal diarrhea
you just heard
from Barbara.
that's not --
cut that crap out.
I'm just going to say that
this opportu--
a little respect here.
Having said all that,
I got to get a door lock.
There's no question about it.
So I'll probably go online
and buy one from you
because you've scared
the pants off me.
Yeah, me too.
But the opportunity is
not evident to me
on how I give you $275,000
and how I make a lot back
because you're missing
so much.
I'm out.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Thank you.
I just know that there's
a huge Market.
There's $1.3 billion spent
on steel garage doors.
Bryan, I don't think
anybody's contesting
that there's
a huge Market there.
But you don't have
the infrastructure in place
for a salesperson,
and that changes
the economics,
and you're looking for us
to do it.
I'm not in a position
to do that,
and so, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
JOHN: I'll tell you
what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
It's a Kevin O'Leary play.
It's put this
in my licensing division
and see if we
can get somebody to...
Oh, grasshopper,
you've learned.
...Go out there
and, uh, do something.
I think that America needs
to know
how to protect themselves,
needs to help themselves.
Every homeowner should know
about this.
I'll give you $275,000
for 40%,
but it's contingent on us
finding a license.
You should say yes.
S-sorry. Hang on.
What was the offer?
$275,000 for 40%,
and my only intention
is to license it.
Here's the offer
I'll make you.
$275,000,
and I want to --
in exchange for 70%.
70%?!
That's my offer.
What is wrong with you?
I have a guy who --
who does this
and sells products
like this.
I have absolutely no doubt
in my mind
I could put you in front
of those buyers immediately.
We have the same exact offers
on the table,
except for Robert,
the greedy savage he is,
he wants to take 70%.
Yeah, Bryan, my --
my friend,
he's the largest manufacturer
of car covers
in North America.
Robert may have
a closer relationship
with this one outlet.
I'm gonna go
after five or six.
Robert wants
to take 70%.
Those offers are usually done
in Nigeria and Kuwait
and things of that nature,
and I want to take...
[ laughs ]
Via e-mail, right?
...Yeah -- 40%.
O'LEARY: Okay, Bryan, we've got
two offers on the table.
You'll get your $275,000
from Daymond.
He wants 40% of the equity,
contingent on licensing it
to a manufacturer that solves
your Marketing problem.
Robert has a special friend
that knows this industry
inside out.
There's no contingency,
but he wants 70%
of any revenue stream.
You keep 30%. He gets 70%.
He'll solve your Marketing and
manufacturing problems also.
But that's a crime.
What are you going to do?
Daymond, would you counter
at 35%?
You got a deal.
Done.
Robert, I really like you.
Don't talk to him.
He's a crook.
HERJAVEC:
Bryan, I hate you!
[ laughter ]
I hate you!
I had no idea.
Bryan, get the hell
out of here!
Thank you.
I'm sorry, Robert.
I hate you!
I really like you.
I like him better.
Oh!
Ouch!
There goes a good man.
Robert, I never heard
an offer from -- from
you like that before.
What happened to you?
It's a lot of work.
I do know
it's a lot of work.
It's a lot of work
to get this done.
Oh, whoa. Yeah.
WHITE: I struck a deal
with a millionaire.
It's gonna get my product
out there.
It just feels fantastic.
I can't even tell you
how I feel.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank is
a quick fix to a daily problem.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Max Valverde.
I'm from Boston, Massachusetts,
and I'm the creator
of Morninghead.
Of what?
Morninghead.
Ah.
Ah. Of course.
I'm seeking $25,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my company.
I try to exercise
every day after work.
I love mountain biking,
rock climbing,
basketball, you name it.
After I get a good sweat going,
I come home,
hit the shower,
and hit the hay.
The next morning,
I'm still totally clean,
but my bed head is insane.
And the last thing I want to do
is take another shower.
For years, I tried wetting
my hair in the sink.
Water gets everywhere,
and you never really get
the back of your head.
Morninghead solves this problem
once and for all.
It's a reusable, washable cap
with a super-absorbent material
on the inside.
Simply add water to it.
Allow that water to absorb.
Put it on your head.
Once it's on your head, you rub
it around for a few seconds.
Let that water absorb
into your hair.
No water dripping
down your neck, mind you,
so you can do it anywhere,
even if you're
fully clothed.
[ laughs ]
and seconds later,
your hair is completely wet.
No mess. Bed head's gone.
You can then style your hair
as you normally would,
as if you just toweled off
after a shower.
Max, what do you
think the chances are I'm
going to invest in that?
[ laughter ]
Kevin, Daymond, Daymond, Kevin,
you guys are the lucky ones.
No hair, no problem,
but for the rest of us,
basically anyone
who's ever had bed head
without the need or the time
for a shower
has a real use
for this product.
Our internet popularity
coupled with your capital
and expertise
ensures Morninghead is poised
to catch a viral wave,
create a paradigm shift
in morning grooming,
and in 12 months' time...
[ laughter ]
...one or more of you
will be able to tell friends
your best move of this year
was getting Morninghead.
Here we go.
This is our first run.
I designed all this,
basically.
Thank you.
This is a diaper
you put on your head.
Hey, it works.
O'LEARY: It's a shower cap.
I think that's
the challenge.
It's a diaper.
Right. But check this.
We'd be lucky if we sold
10, 20, 100 of these things.
We've sold 7,000
in over 42 countries.
This is a big product.
What?
Now it got
a little serious here.
You sold 7,000
of them?
Exactly.
For how much?
So, right now they're --
we're selling them
for $7.99 on our website.
Our cost is $1.19. We're gonna
get that closer to $1.
The margin is sick.
What were your total sales
to date?
To date -- $36,000.
How long have you been
in business?
18 months.
JOHN: Why do you need
the money?
What's the $25,000
gonna do for you?
Here's why we need the money.
If I can purchase
in a slightly larger bracket,
we'll be able to get the cost
from $1.19 down closer to $1.
And how do your customers
find you?
What I've done
is I've made my own videos.
We -- we've had 165,000 views
on our website.
To me, that says for every 1,000
people who sees our video,
sees our Marketing message,
we are getting 34 caps sold.
You're not living
off Morninghead, are you?
No.
What else
do you do?
So, I'm
a mechanical engineer.
I have a list of inventions,
a list of stuff I want to do.
What else you got?
This sucks.
No -- Kevin, think back
to after college
when you had those big --
that big mop of hair.
Yeah.
You never wet your hair
in the sink? You never --
i-i actually did, and I remember
those days fondly.
he never had hair.
But it -- I just can't see
this as a big business, max.
This is basically
a shower cap.
[ laughs ]
VALVERDE: It is. It is.
With a --
with a bumper sticker on it.
But we've sold 7,000 units
in over 42 countries.
No, I get it, max.
It's just -- you know,
it's a tchotchke.
And you're a great sales guy.
Yeah.
What a waste of you.
And so I say you take
some of the other ideas --
what are your other ideas, max?
w-what's next?
Mark, I learned long ago --
about five years ago, I had --
you know, I have pages
of inventions.
I was working on five,
six things at a time.
I really need to devote time
to one thing at a time.
And you've done
a great job of this.
I -- this is
an easy-money product.
It's good.
It's a big hit.
But it's not enormous,
and it's not gonna go anywhere.
You're not gonna be, you know,
on the Forbes 400 --
"the inventor of Morninghead,
$6.7 billion net worth,"
right? there's got --
"retail locations everywhere."
[ laughter ]
VALVERDE: I see what you're
saying, but that's why
I'm not coming in here for
a million-dollar valuation.
We're pricing at --
based on our -- our last
quarter's run rate --
look, I -- I get it.
I love it.
It's hysterical.
If you had told me you have
three different
follow-up products,
I'd invest
in a heartbeat.
But you don't.
For that reason, I'm out.
Well, h-here's the thing,
Mark, is that we are --
our -- our users
have been writing in
asking for bulk orders.
Users are asking --
bulk orders?
Yes.
Well, why wouldn't you
sell it to them?
O'LEARY: Like, max --
no, we are.
We're selling --
what for?
Because they're disposable.
They -- they only last
about six months.
So people are writing in --
what? Oh, no.
So they want five years' worth
of Morninghead?
Yes, they do,
and they're asking for
a subscription-based program.
A subscription-based
program?
[ laughter ]
$2 a month. $2 a month.
Oh!
Max, I have
some good news for you.
Enough. Don't laugh too hard
at the guy.
Ah.
Let me speak up.
May I speak up? All right.
So, max, let me ask you
something. Let me --
wait. No, no.
I'm speaking.
Oh, sorry.
Pipe down, little man.
Barbara's speaking,
young Daymond.
Please.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm your perfect customer,
honest to God,
because I wash my hair
every other day,
and it's true --
the second day,
if you shower at night,
your hair looks terrible.
right.
But bad news for you
is I discovered
another solution.
It's called
a damp face cloth.
I rub it around,
and I have perfect hair.
It's totally unnecessary.
I'm out.
Here's the thing, Barbara.
You of anyone
should know that --
that a funny name
and a gimmick can go a long way
with your "pigtails"
and with --
no, this gimmick is --
yeah, this gimmick is
not gonna go too far.
Max, I just don't see the vision
for this product. I'm out.
Max, it's not
a scalable business for me.
It's an item, and I think
you're gonna make a good
amount of money
and have some fun with it,
but I can't help you here.
I'm out.
Kevin, come on,
work with me here, Kevin.
No, no, no.
You like --
this -- no,
this -- this --
this company --
high growth potential.
You'll get
your $25,000 back.
Max, max.
No problem.
This qualifies
as poo-poo on a stick.
I'm out. I'm out.
Good luck.
Good luck, max.
Thank you.
Good luck to you guys.
Thank you very much.
Let's try it out.
Wait. There's merit
in the product.
[ laughs ]
VALVERDE:
All laughing aside,
Morninghead is
a serious business,
and contrary to what
the sharks are saying,
Morninghead is going to be
a million-dollar company.
NARRATOR: Next up is
an affordable study solution
for starving students.
Hey, sharks.
My name is Kasey gandham.
And I'm Mike Shannon.
We're from Chicago,
Illinois,
and our company
is packback books.
We're seeking $200,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Sharks, let me ask
you all a question.
Do you remember what it was like
to be a college student?
Well, sharks, there's been
a serious epidemic on the rise
since your college days,
and it's the cost of textbooks.
Hey, Mark, did you know
that since the time when you
hung up your Hoosier hat,
textbook prices
have risen 812%?
In fact, the students
are even dropping out
of their courses
in order to avoid
the book cost.
They are compromising
their education.
But that's not the worst
that can happen.
Take a look at this.
When you buy textbooks
from the book store,
you end up broke.
[ groans ]
when you end up broke,
you have to get a job
cleaning windows
on campus.
When you clean windows
on campus, you look in and see
parts of your professor
you wish you hadn't.
huh? aah!
When you see things
you wish you hadn't, you
fall off a 10-story building.
[ groans ]
when you fall off
a 10-story building,
You wind up
in a full-body cast
and can't lug
your expensive books to class.
When you can't lug
your expensive books to class,
you sadly flunk
out of college.
oh, no!
And when you flunk
out of college,
you end up back in
your mom's basement...
Hi!
...Eating cookies
on the couch in a onesie.
[ groans ]
don't end up eating cookies
on the couch in a onesie.
Use packback books.
Clever.
SHANNON:
Packback books is a website
offering pay-per-use access
to digital textbooks.
A student simply logs in,
selects the book they need,
and bam, they have
immediate, affordable
access to their books.
Our e-textbooks
are fully equipped
with highlighting
and note-taking capabilities,
and we're already working with
major U.S. textbook publishers
to bring the packback service
to students nationwide.
Sharks, who's ready to pack
smart with packback books?
O'LEARY: You're walking
right into my space here.
Let's say
I'm Houghton Mifflin,
and I'm doing curriculum books
for the New York Market.
I already offer them
in a digital format.
Are you saying you're
just letting me lease
the digital format?
Absolutely.
So, the way
our service works --
let's say Daymond is
a sophomore in college.
He's fed up. Freshman year,
he spent $1,200 on new books.
He realized he didn't use
half of them
enough for
the purchase price.
We allow Daymond to hold off
on buying anything.
Rent for a day at a time
at $5 or less,
as is a quiz
or a homework assignment.
So, Mike,
I'm going to assume that,
if you're in this business,
you have a deal
with the largest publishers
in that space.
that's right.
We have a deal with one
of the biggest four.
One of the largest.
What percentage of the books
would that cover?
So, it's roughly anywhere
from 25% to 30%,
depending on your --
on your average campus.
And if it works,
you'll get the other ones.
Right, so --
but why wouldn't one
of the big guys just do this?
It's their -- it's their
property you're renting
out anyway.
Yes. E-textbooks
are being sold.
They've been around
in the Marketplace for
around eight years, but --
HERJAVEC:
But they're only being sold.
They're being rented
for a semester
at approximately
$100 to $150 per book. now --
but you're doing it
differently --
the only difference being
you're doing it by the day.
We're introducing
a micro-transaction into this --
you're -- you're pay-per-view.
Yeah, we're pay-per--
pay-per-use.
Yeah, so --
what's a typical price
for a textbook?
Your new book
could be $150.
All right.
A used book could be
as low as $89.
So, semester's starting.
In your format, how much
is it gonna cost me?
We rent digital books
for $5 a day.
What's the average amount of
days that a student downloads?
What we found was that --
we're in a closed beta
with 330 students at one campus.
They're using their books only
on four main occasions.
We're seeing the -- the revenue
on an average student
that -- that packbacks --
for our portion of the share --
$34 per semester.
Tell me your cost
to the publisher.
So, the publishers receive
75% of revenue.
Ouch.
CORCORAN: Yeah.
SHANNON:
So -- and this is --
that's the deal
you've negotiated right now?
75%?
GANDHAM: This is -- so, this is
a standard industry --
industry licensing agreement
for all e-books.
So we think we --
you know,
we might be able to get
up to 30% on our end.
You don't -- y-you have
no exclusivity
with any of these publishers,
right?
'cause I've worked with these
guys for over a decade, okay?
They don't give exclusivity.
That's correct.
Right, so we --
we absolutely know
that there's
a first-mover advantage
to be taken advantage of
right here.
The major players
in this space,
they're all selling
used books.
But the textbook industry
is an $8 billion industry.
$6 billion of that
are used books.
Everyone's buying a used --
but what's that got to do
with your Market?
Because if -- if --
if an Amazon or a chegg
were to offer
daily e-textbook rentals,
they'd be directly cannibalizing
their used books.
They're in so much trouble
because this used-book Market
is -- is such a disaster
for their revenue.
What percentage
of the student population
are actually renting
their books
versus buying them
in the first place?
The average student
will spend about $500
a semester
on used books.
Okay, so now he's gonna rent
on a typical --
at least.
The publisher didn't
get a dime of that
money, of those dollars.
Okay, but he's now gonna
rent from you instead on
a daily basis?
Correct.
So, what does that
come out to?
In one year, he's going
to spend about $280.
Oh.
So it's a great savings?
It's an amazing savings.
I don't know
if it's a great saving.
My son, he looks at his textbook
a lot more than four times.
I mean, that's four days
in an entire semester?
What we found in our research,
it doesn't --
are you telling me my kids are
only looking at their textbooks,
on average,
four times a semester?
Robert, it's not because
they're not studying.
It's because the professors
have a wealth of resources
to put out
the necessary information.
The book is
one more resource.
It's not the --
the end-all, be-all.
Kasey and Mike,
this is -- this --
so, Mike,
your entire pitch is,
to the publisher,
"I'm giving you revenue
that you're not getting"?
correct.
Wow. So, guys, this is
the beauty about "Shark Tank."
all the sharks have so much
knowledge in different spaces.
I got to this place
in my life
by having drive
and common sense.
But, tell you the truth,
I didn't go to college,
and I'm dyslexic,
so I can barely read.
I like to invest
in businesses
that I have some expertise in
so I can help them grow.
I don't have any knowledge
in this business, so I'm out.
We appreciate it --
appreciate it, Daymond.
Okay, thank you very much
for your time.
You know what I think?
I think you're having
a much harder time
selling this thing
than you're telling us.
I admire your persistence,
but I think you're gonna have
a heck of a hard time,
and I can't imagine
all the publishers
going along for the ride.
Perhaps I'm being negative,
but I'm out.
So, that kind of plays
into --
I'm out.
You're out? Thank you
very much for your time.
Thanks, Barbara.
We appreciate it.
Guys, I like
what you're doing, okay?
I-i know your --
your industry inside out.
I have personally
negotiated deals
with all of those publishers
for over a decade.
I will give you one small piece
of advice.
It'll take you a lot longer
than you think to get the deals.
Oh, we know.
Okay.
We spent two years as students
going through this ourselves.
And -- and -- it -- well,
it sends a tingle up my spine
to get back
into the education Market,
which is where I made
the bulk of my net worth.
Sure.
I can't go back there.
If I walk
into those offices again,
I'd rip the rest
of my hair out.
Redbox and Netflix,
they -- they weren't --
and iTunes -- they weren't
overnight successes.
It's important
that you're young,
'cause by the time you finish
with the educational publishers,
you will be very old, okay?
Right. But --
and -- and I'm not saying it's
not a noble pursuit.
I have spent thousands of hours
in their offices.
You will have no hair.
You will both look like me
when this is over.
CORCORAN: [ laughs ]
I am out.
Thanks, Kevin.
Thank you very much.
Guys --
um, here's what
we think it takes.
It takes
the right context.
When we find
the right individuals
within the organization,
things click.
HERJAVEC: Mike, look.
I guess it comes down to --
you know, everything's
a gut feel, right?
Everything -- everything you
invest in in life is a gut feel.
I just don't share
your vision for this product.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thanks, Robert.
Thank you -- thank you
very much for the time.
Who's left? Mark?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
I like the concept.
I mean, I'm already
in tech Ed --
degreed, ranku,
copley systems, hourlynerd.
I mean, I'm -- I'm in a bunch,
so I get the space, right?
But 10% isn't enough.
And I want you guys
to come back to me
and tell me what's
the most equity I can get,
how, and how much.
Right. Um...
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Mark is interested,
but he's not happy
with the amount of equity
being offered.
CUBAN: Okay.
I like the concept.
But 10% isn't enough.
And I want you guys
to come back to me
and tell me what's
the most equity I can get,
how, and how much.
Right. Um...
You can talk.
Talk?
Let's go talk about it.
What if we just ask him
for more?
Ask him for more money
and offer, uh...
15% for $300,000?
That's the same valuation.
Yeah. It'd be the same.
Look, if you look at it
as pay-per-view for text,
then the fact that it --
that it's textbooks now...
CORCORAN: Mm-hmm.
...That's just a start.
In near-term, negotiating those,
uh, publisher agreements
is gonna take
a long time.
Yeah, I think they
can get past that
because they don't have to be
completely dependent,
just pay-per-view.
yeah.
Mark, we agree
with what you're saying.
We really value you
as an investor.
We want you to be very much
vested into packback's growth.
We would like to offer you
17.5% for $200,000.
What about $250,000
for 20%?
Would you do --
would you be ab--
willing to do
$200,000 for the 20%?
What?!
Yes.
No. No. That's not --
[ laughter ]
no, you're --
no, that's not --
no, we're thinking.
we're thinking.
We're thinking. No, no.
Sit down, sit down, sit down.
I-i-i meant -- yeah.
No, no, he --
he did it wrong.
Are you sure you want to be
in a deal with these guys?
Let's hit
the rewind button on that.
Yeah, so, we --
we would AC--
we'll accept your deal.
We would like to accept
your deal, Mark.
250-- I'll cut you guys
a break.
$250,000 for 20% equity.
For 20%. There you go. Yes.
[ laughter ]
Thanks, Mark.
Appreciate it.
All right, that was --
all right.
congrats, guys. it'll be fun.
You guys wouldn't have
been best friends anymore
after that one.
[ laughter ]
It's all right.
Thank you, guys.
JOHN: Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
What I actually meant
to say was
we were hoping to get
$250,000 at the 17.5%.
I may, uh...
[ laughs ]
I'm, uh -- I'm a sharp kid.
I can do math.
But, uh, when you're
in the tank,
it's -- it's not
that easy, right?
Yeah, that was
a code red.